Hungary's biggest anti-government
protests in years demonstrators want to
keep the Central European University
open it was founded by billionaire
philanthropist George Soros whose open
society foundation promotes
international cooperation and democratic
initiatives that's in direct opposition
to Prime Minister Viktor orbán's
increasingly authoritarian and
nationalist moves in recent years the
university is one of the best in Central
Europe and I think it's only sin is that
it was founded by mr. Soros here's the
government's number-one enemy but the
university doesn't deserve to be shut
down
and we are in favor of keeping it open a
measure rushed through Parliament last
week sets new conditions for the 28
foreign universities operating in
Hungary the country's president Janos
are there still has to sign the bill by
Monday to make it law the protesters
want order to veto the legislation to
the University to continue operating
I feel like this party doesn't like
foreign influence that kind of
challenges Hungarian institutions the
seniors American and it has actually a
better standard than the Hungarian
institutions maybe that's kind of a
threat kind of the challenge you know
even though it's not political if
Sunday's demonstration does not get the
resort protesters are calling for the
CEU may be forced to close or move to
another country